President Trump is lashing out at the
FBI as the Russian investigation moves
closer to the White House the president
used Twitter to attack the bureau's
credibility he said this weekend that
the FBI's reputation is the worst in
history fired FBI director James Comey
responded with a quote from his own
Capitol Hill testimony earlier this year
call me tweeted this I want the American
people to know this truth the FBI is
honest
the FBI is strong and the FBI is and
will always be independent
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with this intensifying feud Margaret
good morning good morning
it is stunning for any American
president to publicly rebuke the law
enforcement agency but President Trump
has been harshly critical of the FBI
throughout its probe of his campaigns
activities before leaving the White
House this morning President Trump said
Michael Flynn didn't deserve harsh
treatment on Friday Flynn pleaded guilty
to lying to the FBI about his contacts
with Russia the president then compared
it to the FBI's treatment of Hillary
Clinton she lied many times nothing
happened to her over the weekend the
president unleashed an attack on the FBI
saying on Twitter its reputation is in
tatters and accused it of a dishonest
investigation of Hillary Clinton former
director James Comey testified that the
president fired him after the FBI did
not honor a request to stop
investigating Flynn as part of the
Russia probe what he wanted me to do was
drop any investigation connected to
Flynn's account of his conversations
with the Russians the president denied
that account but seemed to suggest that
he was aware that Flynn had lied to the
FBI tweeting Saturday quote I had to
fire general Flynn because he lied to
the vice president and the FBI which
raises new questions about what the
president knew and when South Carolina
Republican Lindsey Graham warned the
post appeared incriminating you tweeting
comment regarding ongoing criminal
investigations at your own peril I'd be
careful if I were you mr. pres
sources close to the White House tell
CBS News that in an unusual move it was
the president's lawyer John Dowd who
helped write that tweet congressman Adam
Schiff said it hurts the president he
wanted to protect Mike Flynn lying on
his behalf and then you do get very
close to a case of obstruction of
justice
the president's attorney John Dowd told
CBS News that he considers these
questions of whether the president
obstructed justice to be the result of
what he called quote the arrogance and
ignorance of the media and opposition he
argues that since the president is the
chief law enforcement officer of the
country in his legal view it's
impossible for the president to obstruct
himself it was a strong rebuttal from
Jim Comey Margaret thank you